PRIYANKA VERGADIA: You've gone
through the migration process
and are ready to move your
first microservice to GKE.
In today's episode,
let's see how.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARTER MORGAN: Let's consider
the Ice Cream Theory, which
is an online ice cream parlor.
They're on this journey to
migrate their monolith website
to microservices, and
they're looking for guidance
in moving their first
microservice to GKE.
So we'll walk them through
the migration in stages.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, we'll need
to run an assessment of
their current environment
to determine how many public
endpoints we will need
and what needs to move.
But we'll get to that
in the next episode.
For now, let's assume
that they have picked up
a feature that makes sense
to start with this migration.
CARTER MORGAN: Before we start
converting their chosen feature
to a microservice on GKE, let's
see how to prepare their GCP
environment.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well,
before they migrate the legacy
components, they will
need a place to put them.
And for that, they will
need a GCP organization.
CARTER MORGAN: Then
they need to ensure
that only people with
the right authorization
can access the
resources, so they
need to design GCP
policies to control access
to the GCP resources.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
And once that's
taken care of, it's
time to create a plan
to deploy the resources in
a standardized reproducible
way using
infrastructure as a code
utilizing tools like Deployment
Manager and Terraform.
CARTER MORGAN: At this point, we
recommend the Ice Cream Theory
team to study GKE
and its features
so that they can tweak
them for their needs.
This will mean changing
some of GKE's defaults
and maybe hardening
the cluster security.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Once GKE is set up,
it's time to build
the CI/CD pipeline.
They can use their
existing tools
like Spinnaker or Jenkins, or
they can use the GCP products
like Cloud Build and
Container Registry
to build, store, and scan
those container images.
Doing this early in the
project will avoid problems
when they are in production.
CARTER MORGAN: And
remember the last episode
where we discussed communication
options between Google Cloud
and on premise's data centers?
Well, they would need to decide
whether an API-based solution
like Apigee or a private
connection like Cloud
Interconnect is better
for their needs.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Now that we
have our GCP environment set
up, which is kind
of like preheat
the oven to start
the actual cooking,
it's time to start migrating
the legacy platform or with GCP.
CARTER MORGAN: Overall, we
recommend that Ice Cream Theory
migrate there features
of the website one by one
to the new environment creating
microservices will require.
Those microservices can call
back to the legacy system
whenever they need.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Migrating in stages
like this has two advantages.
Smaller projects are easier
to work with, minimize errors,
and costly mistakes,
and it lets you
handle each individual migration
without getting overwhelmed.
CARTER MORGAN: The
first thing to analyze
is the dependencies of
the shopping cart feature
on the rest of the system.
We can do that by
reasoning through the steps
the user takes when
interacting with the website.
The user makes the ice
cream selection and clicks
Add to My Shopping Cart.
That triggers an API call
from the user's browser
to the shopping cart.
Once the shopping cart
receives the call,
it checks whether
the chosen ice cream
is in stock by making an API
call to the inventory system.
If the item is in stock, the
shopping cart stores the info,
something like Carter has one
instance of item strawberry ice
cream in the cart.
Finally, when the
user checks out
and goes through
the payment process,
the shopping cart is queried
by the payment subsystem
to compute the total.
And once the
payment is complete,
the payment subsystem
notifies the shopping cart
feature to empty the cart.
So if we analyze
this at a high level,
this shopping cart feature
has four dependencies.
It is called by the front end
and the payment subsystem,
and it queries a database
in the inventory system.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Now
that we have identified
the dependencies, let's give
some thought to the choice
of database for this feature.
A document database is
well-suited for storing
shopping carts since shopping
carts can be easily indexed
by user IDs, and you
don't need the power
of relational database here.
Cloud Firestore is a great
fit for this purpose.
It's a managed and serverless
no SQL document database,
so let's consider that for
our target architecture.
CARTER MORGAN: Now
comes the biggest piece,
migrating the actual
shopping cart feature.
Assuming Ice Cream Theory
can schedule a maintenance
for their website--
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Wait, wait, wait.
I don't know when is
down time for ice creams.
I know I can eat ice creams
in the middle of the night.
[CHUCKLING]
CARTER MORGAN: I know.
Well, let's assume that they
can do scheduled maintenance.
First, they would need to
create a new microservice that
can call the inventory
system and uses
Cloud Firestore to implement
a shopping cart API.
Then create a script that
extracts shopping cart entries
from the legacy
shopping cart system
and writes them the
Cloud Firestore.
This script needs to
be written in a way
that it can be rerun
as many times as needed
but only copies
the shopping carts
that have been changed
since last time.
Then create a script that
does the opposite, which
is it copies shopping
carts from Cloud Firestore
back to the legacy subsystem
in case they need to roll back
the migration.
Then expose the shopping
cart API with Apigee.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: They would
need to prepare and test
the modification to the
front end and payment systems
so they can call the new
shopping cart system.
Again comes the time to
run the data migration
script we prepared earlier
so all the data is in sync,
and we did not lose any shopping
cart records in the process.
CARTER MORGAN: At
this point, they
need to put their website
in maintenance mode
and rerun the data
migration script.
Deploy the tests
and modifications
done to the front end
and the payment system
on the legacy production system.
Once done, they're ready
to disable the maintenance
mode in the website.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: And with
that, the shopping cart feature
of the Ice Cream
Theory website is now
microservice hosted
on Google Cloud.
The hardest step
of this process is
where they had to make changes
to the legacy payment and front
end system, but that gets
easier as they migrate
more and more features to
microservices because more
and more of the dependencies
will already be microservices.
As such, they are
more loosely coupled
than in monolithic application
and are easier to modify
and deploy.
CARTER MORGAN: For
more information
about alternative
migration approaches,
check out the article
written by Marco and Te'o.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, there you have it.
If you are looking to migrate
a monolithic application
to microservices,
you've got a small taste
of the steps involved through
the Ice Cream Theory's use
case.
Stay tuned for the
next episode where
we will talk about deciding
what to migrate first.
Until then, try the
end-to-end migration
of an e-commerce website
in the code lab link below.
CARTER MORGAN:
That's all for today
on "Get Cooking in Cloud."
If you like what
we're cooking here
and would like to
see more recipes,
don't forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.